it happened again what did you make of
that Ryan Gosling Saturday Night Live
Papyrus it's haunted me
not really I couldn't give a [__] I
forgot about it for years but then I
remember it then after
I have giant International Blockbuster
use the Papyrus font as its logo it is
pretty funny I'm just astonished that
they spent that much money on a little
cinematic vignette that's around such a
you know wispy thin concept and so now
you're worried about the sequels they're
making more I said all right guys we are
now doubling down we're using Papyrus
for everything you just
got away with it the funniest thing
about that whole story is I didn't even
know it was Papyrus nobody asked me I
just thought the art Department had come
up with this cool fun yeah I